good morning hank it's esther day and i
love you
11 years ago when we asked our friend
esther earl what holiday we should
celebrate in her honor on her birthday
she imagined a holiday where people
celebrated all the kinds of
non-romantic love the love in
friendships and
families that too often goes unspoken
like what is it that makes it so hard
for me to tell my brother that i love
him when i love him
so much so much that i feel the ache of
it behind my solar plexus
it's almost embarrassing hank to talk
about how deeply and dearly
i love you it feels like looking
directly at the sun or
confessing a secret it feels vulnerable
and maybe that's what makes it hard to
say i dislike feeling vulnerable even
though
it is essential to the human experience
to loving
and being loved so yeah i love you
esther knew that non-romantic love
didn't get enough attention and she
certainly knew that i
rarely if ever said i love you to hank
and so
she gave us esther day and i am so
grateful for it
esther died just a few weeks after the
first esther day
in 2010 she was 16 and after her death
her parents founded an
extraordinary charity called this star
won't go out that provides direct
financial support to families of kids
with cancer
childhood cancer treatment can be very
expensive in the united states but there
are also many indirect
costs especially when a parent has to
leave work
to care for their child this star won't
go out allows families to spend more
time with their kids and hopefully worry
a little bit less about the financial
burdens of serious illness and i am
just amazed by what wayne and lori have
accomplished in the last 10 years
tonight at 8 p.m eastern this star won't
go out's annual gala will be
virtual and there will be many special
guests including the one
and only sarah euresta green so i hope
to see you there the event is free
although
of course there will be opportunities to
donate link in the doobly-doo also if
you're new to nerdfighteria and want to
learn more about esther i really
recommend her book which is also called
this star won't go out in the weeks
after esther died our community talked a
lot about wanting to do things not just
for esther or in memory of esther
but with esther we wanted to feel her
presence in our ongoing work
and to carry her legacy with us for me
anyway there is no writing the wrong
of esther's illness and death and no
minimizing the grief of those who loved
her
but i am very proud of the way
nerdfighteria has responded to esther's
calling
i see that response in the thousands of
people who celebrate esther day telling
their friends and families they love
them and i see it in our community's
commitment to improving child health
including pediatric cancer care in
impoverished communities
and i see it in nerdfighteria's ongoing
support for this star won't go out
in all these projects for me esther's
memory lights the way
and i hope we can continue with them for
many years
but more immediately i hope that
wherever you are in the world you will
have a moment today to acknowledge the
love in your life
especially the kinds of love that are
hard to say out loud we are only here
for a little while and i know for me it
sometimes feels like i have to protect
myself from
cracking open like i have to close
myself off with cynicism
and irony so that i don't feel too much
too directly
but today just for today let's gather
our courage
and be with esther and say what we mean
hank i love you i am so grateful to you
for loving me for growing with me and
for all the stuff we get to do together
thank you i will see you on friday p.s i
really hope to see you tonight at the
esther day gala again
link in the doobly-doo also i feel like
esther would want a joke in this video
and there isn't one
but something did just happen to me in
between takes so here it is
sneezing is never normal i never sneeze